okay we're back here with everybody on
the Internet so much body regulation
like in your monologue now we're free
finally right we are we could be
completely free open your shirt if you
okay alright no [ __ ] now it's an
entertainment show Olivia what do you
make of the strange relationship between
Trump and Scarborough and Brzezinski
those are the hosts of our morning news
show called Morning Joe before you did
[Laughter]
your president well he used to be
friends right is that the deal and then
they became unfriendly and he accused
her of having a bad facelift it was just
yeah I mean they were friendly Joe
Scarborough was accused of being too
kind to him throughout the election when
it really you know mattered in terms of
people taking him seriously at the
beginning especially he turned yeah they
did become critical and and you know
sort of in a very emotional way it
seemed personal and personal from them
or Trump both I mean Trump was you know
Chuck started attacking them in a really
vitriolic way you know even more than a
year ago insinuating that they had some
kind of you know personal relationship
that was untoward in some way which they
do and you know aren't they a couple
yeah but on tour they said he was kind
of about it he was sort of he was
suggesting that there was something
going on there was no fan what's or not
anyway very savory bill something sleazy
[Laughter]
and then as president you know he
attacked her for having plastic surgery
and claimed rose incorrectly there were
photos of this event that she was
bleeding at Marla yeah
so it's obsessed with that his knees the
iconography of femininity that's
actually true misogyny yeah no he's a
bed he's a bad dude I'm getting the idea
you don't like him I don't like him and
he sued me once you know yeah absolutely
sued me all night you can't I could not
even I'll try to tell you I he you know
he had a birther thing he cook used
Obama of not being born here okay okay
after Obama released his birth
certificate Ben Trump went after his
college records as if it was efficient
that a black eye would be in college
he's working his way for his life in the
college and then who knows what next
so I said I this corner logical right
back in a way is more than I thought um
capable of he understands how time works
one aspect immediate time idiot time
right yeah it totally could happen I
don't we need a little less regulation
but what the story all right let me
finish all right so he offered
he offered obama trump offered obama
five million dollars if he would release
his college records I know that itself
is so gauche to offer the president
Vaughn's got it's vulgar vulgar man okay
so I as a joke offered Trump five
million dollars if he could prove he was
not the son of an orangutan because we
showed
[Applause]
we had this up Meritage
so this [ __ ] then sues me too because
he went into court with his birth
certificate
I made Trump produce his birth
certificate because he's such an idiot
he went in as if it was going to say
orangutan on the budget is even possible
for a human to have a baby with it and
so he sued me for the 5 million dollars
because he proved he wasn't in a race I
can't even fundamentally misunderstood
the theory of evolution it's so stupid
but he just loves to [ __ ] with people
you can look at so many things that he's
done now in the White House and explain
it I think oh well he's just [ __ ]
with people which is not what you want
in a president obviously which is not a
partisan thing to say it's just factual
it doesn't mean I'm on a team it's just
factual to say I don't have a right I go
with whoever makes the most sense which
is mostly the Democrats not always
Harold is the Democratic Party moving
too far left some parts of it are and
like I define left but just sort of
being unrealistic about what can get
done the Democrats came out I guess it
was a few months ago with a plan called
a better deal will help what our dip
plan was to help grow the economy and
create more jobs and raise wages that'll
start a fire right and it didn't it
didn't really resonate with anybody I
think we got to talk about growing again
we got to talk about protecting people's
privacy this equifax thing where people
hundred forty million Americans had
their their data stolen we as a party
got to stand up for that but at the same
time figure out how we're gonna grow
businesses grow wages and for that
matter grow the economy and we can do it
without taking from people we can do it
by by growing the economy when we do
that I think we'll begin to get on path
to getting something that will resonate
with more Americans because something as
much as we talk about this guy and it's
out of out of control as he is on
foreign policy and economic ideas he won
the race and it was nine months it seems
like it was nine years ago it was only
nine ten months ago that he was
neighbors installed as president we've
got to understand we're not going to
when again just by complaining about him
if he offers a tax plan we've got a
counter with a tax plan if he offers a
health plan that's bad we've got to
offer health plan that's better I think
what Bernie Sanders did around the
single-payer plan I like Obamacare I
didn't I think parts of it are work and
we've got to figure out how we shored up
and strengthen it to abandon it like
Bernie wanted to do right away I don't
think was the right thing to do and
certainly not what the Republicans
proposed doing so we got two ways to go
we'll find our way there and we might
even get Russell Brand to help us
articulate this plus what's required I
don't understand a word you're saying
but I love listening to you some
mistakes were made around the time of
the Boston Tea Party King George don't
seem so bad now
all right final question Russell bread
what is the sleaziest thing you ever did
oh don't say that I've done some if it's
that sleazy things and now I'm really
sleep sleazo in your past like what was
the craziest orgy or whatever you know
what what what is the moment being
together brand Easter hot tub party then
I'm telling you that was a religious
festival by the end of it that hot tub
looked like oatmeal is a different
matter
[Applause]